um i think i would define it as i'm
passionate about technology
so startups that are working on
cutting-edge technology
and and also making customers happy
[Music]
michael blumenthal thank you so much for
being on my show how are you
i'm great how are you michael thank you
so much for having me on your wonderful
show
i am fantastic but you actually go by by
michael in the us right not mikhail
very true mikhail in israel michael in
the u.s when i just moved here everyone
thought i would go by
by michelle i just didn't feel like a
michelle michael is
you know a good conversation starter and
it's memorable which is always good for
business
i love it i love it memorable always
good for business okay so and we have to
start with this fun fact
which we've already shared with with our
audience but folk dancing horror
most people watching this are not gonna
know what hora is even if they're from
israel so let's we have to spend a few
minutes talking about folk dancing
what is this and why have you been doing
this for 14 years
that's a good question professionally
everyone thinks of
folk the israeli folk dancing is just a
big group of people dancing in a circle
right
so that's not that's not what it is it's
actually a very very professional
um thing to do you know the company
performed all over the world
so when i was 15 we went to brazil for a
whole month
and we performed in let's see paris
berlin russia event so it's a and it's a
great thing to do it
it really built my character i have to
say so
so talk to give me a little bit of
context into what it actually is
you know tangibly so it's basically
any type of dancing if it's played to an
israeli song
that's pretty much what it is it started
when um when the first settlers came
into israel they built
the new jewish country and they they
they took some of the
traditional dancing that they brought
from their own country like it used to
be russia and poland
and and they implemented it into a new
type of israeli folk dancing
and it's really evolved over the years
there's lots of different groups in
israel right now
and it's it's not it's no longer
constrained to just a
traditional dancing it's now very modern
dancing and
that's why i'm saying it's pretty much
anything that is played over an israeli
song in the background
so so when you're saying professionally
like what what does that actually mean
to do to do this professionally it means
that you have a choreographer right that
builds
the dance and you have a group of people
that train a lot
we we train about twice or three times a
week for
for two hours every time we do ballet
ballet um training and modern training
and it's it's mainly um in groups of two
so
a man and a woman dancing together to
the same choreography
so that is the bathrooms the whole
costumes the whole bank
the whole shipping this is definitely
something something different than what
i imagined i
was i'm thinking back to you know 60s
and 70s videos of people you know
dancing together in large circles and
but i definitely have to go check this
out
and this is actually a pretty nice segue
to something that we we chatted about
earlier which is this whole notion of
of the integration of performing arts
with uh you know with business and with
technology
and you're running a startup hiro ai and
and
we'll get to talk about you know the nlp
side of things but but i first i want to
talk about this whole notion of
of performing arts with with business
and startups
absolutely i think that's performing
takes a big role in what i do
professionally
i think i associated the performance
with the professionalism
in the israeli army that was the first
time it occurred to me so
i was very fortunate to be in a200 you
know
like many israelis in the tech world
it's the intelligence
corp technological unit and i was
working on a project the cyber security
project
and that was very successful i don't
know how to say it in english but in
hebrew we say we scored it
how do you how do you translate it
okay great so we started and then um
all the leaders of the israeli army and
defense
you know came in we had to present the
project to them
and that's the first time where i was
standing in front of the chief of staff
the israeli
army chief of staff and i felt like i'm
taking
everything i learned from performing and
dancing to to this
to this world and it's really it's
really about engaging your audience and
making them you know pretty much adore
you and and and relate to what you're
saying and what you're doing and making
sure your messaging
is accurate and i think it relates
perfectly to that world
and then later on you know it's um it's
in in conferences being presenting at
the booth
it's in even in company meetings and
sales demos
obviously it's in every everything you
do and
you can see that this is the stage i
have uh right now for
for my zoo meetings i have to say that i
cannot resonate more and you know we've
recorded almost 200 episodes of this
show and i'm and i'm you know i'm so
happy that we're talking about this this
is something that i
you know i've been reflecting lately so
but actually by the time this comes out
hopefully a book that i've been writing
will come out and a significant part of
it
will have been about you know my
experience you know with my father
taking me on stage for a tech conference
at 13 years old not knowing anything but
but learning slowly the importance of
being able to deliver messages in a
coherent and concise way that's also
engaging
and then reflecting on how important is
when you're leading teams and i'm sure
that not only in public speaking but
also when you're leading your team
with a startup and the way you're
communicating and engaging your your
employees and your your
the people that are running this
adventure with you it's just as crucial
give me some some insight into what the
specific things that you're
that you've learned over the years about
you know expressing your opinions and
delivering messages
in an in not an entertaining way but an
engaging way that that makes people want
to listen to you and
and like he said adore you i think the
secret is in preparing i always say that
my superpower is that i'm always
prepared
and i have to say i was a bit nervous
about this one because there is no way
to prepare
i'm sorry because i didn't prepare you
at all this is meant to be spontaneous
but but but i already adore you and
i'm very very engaged so you're doing a
good job with the performing arts
already
stop it no i'm kidding and so i think
preparing is key here
and making sure you know exactly what
you want to say how you want to say it
storytelling is also very key in
performance and that you know who you're
talking to
in advance i always like to prepare like
where the person is from what he cares
about
a good tip for for sales is to check
their linkedin account and see
what they posted about so what do they
care about what are they passionate
about
and and building a genuine conversation
around that
right so i a lot of people say that when
you go on stage
you want to start with a joke right that
always loosens the audience but but it
sounds like what you're saying when
you're talking to when you're in sales
or when you're talking to somebody
in business knowing something that
they're curious about and bringing that
up
is is just as important as as jokes so
i'd love to talk a little bit about now
a hiro and what you're doing there and
and i'll bring back performing outside
this conversation just because
i'm i'm so excited to talk about it
finally but but talk to me a little bit
about the start that you're running now
absolutely so i'm the chief operating
officer at hiro we're an innovative
startup we're backed by top vcs
i'm here in the bay area i'm from
oakland by the way um
in new york and in tel aviv so all
around
and we're doing the next next generation
of virtual assistants so
chat bots for website voice assistant
for call centers and we have this
cutting-edge approach for natural
language processing or
how are we able to understand what the
user is saying or asking
so virtual assistants bots
conversational ai
paint me the ecosystem it's getting to
be pretty popular almost any website
that i go on that
is trying to sell me something it does
so very successful because i love
engaging with the virtual bots
and you know the famous touring test of
do you know either you're speaking to a
machine or a person
it's becoming more and more relevant
talk to me about this ecosystem and then
i'd love to talk more about
actually the the company okay absolutely
so
conversational ai is the set of
technologies that enables human to
interact with technology right so think
alexa google home siri all those great
stuff and that includes chatbots so if
we focus on chatbots
if you if you think about the the
chatbot experiences that you had
it it has two main categories so you
have the dumbbots
those are the boxes everything is
pre-configured there so it's all buttons
and and if and else and you know you
have to think in advance of all the
possible questions users can ask
and provide all the possible answers in
advance that's the world of dumb
chatbots that's the most common ones
then if you do have an open text field
which means that you allow users to say
whatever they want
it pretty much it means that you have
natural language processing and
understanding right you have to be able
to break down the sentence understand
what the user is asking about
and that's where natural language
processing kicks in and then for that
world
we have the traditional approach it's
funny to call it traditional because
it's a relatively new field anyway but
that's what most solutions use and
they're all built on
intents so for example when you say
alexa what's the weather like today
that's a weather query intent right
and a similar intent would be asking
how hot is it going to be today or
what's the temperature like going to be
today and should i wear a sweater today
so the same intent right so for the in
order for the ai
and to identify or recognize that intent
you have to provide something that's
called training data right so you have
to provide all the similar
phrasing that i just mentioned in order
for the ai to understand
this intent and recognize it and it's a
very long process
it takes a lot of manual work it's
called tagging similar conversations
and it's very expensive and it's limited
to the intensity already supported right
not very scalable so what we do at
higher we have this whole new approach
for conversational ai which i'm super
excited about
instead of moduling intents we module
the language itself
so we learn we use computational
linguistics and we learn all the
different language rules
like how to identify the verb in a
sentence or how to identify the nouns in
the sentence
which means that we understand in real
time what the user is asking and so
we're able to get a very high quality of
conversation super fast
what you're doing what you're doing is
is literally you know it's it's also
almost like third and fourth grade
grammar classes uh you know
to when kids have to learn they're not
just learning the intent
they're learning about how do how are
sentences formed
because when you read a sentence only by
knowing the formation of the sentence
sometimes you can really understand what
the person means
sometimes when you just add a comma
somewhere you're changing the whole
intent of the sentence
the famous example is obviously from
hamilton i believe with angelica
where she or she there's a whole song
about how she's there's a misplaced
comma and it changes the whole meaning
of the sentence right
yes and peggy don't forget peggy i'll er
the most important of course uh i want
to also want to talk about scalable
processes
and and one thing that we either you
mentioned earlier is this idea of
you know running scalable processes and
and and
scrum master agile so you're the chief
operating officer first of all give me a
two sentence brief what is uh the chief
operating officer in your eyes
so it varies tremendously from each
between
different organizations for us
specifically i'm overseeing all the
commercial aspects of the company
and so sales business development
partnerships
and all of those and product market fit
and so on and it can be it can mean
different things for different
organizations sometimes it means
managing a legal and hr
and things like that um that's what i'm
doing for
for hira what was the second question
well it's specifically you know being a
scrum master and running agile and jira
you've done this in several
organizations it's something that
that it sounds like you're at least a
little bit passionate about it and i'd
love to
learn a little bit more about running
skillable processes
i'm super passionate about the building
scalable processes i'm
a i'm a jira geek i would say um
i've actually been called the jira queen
in every organization i went to
because i like to roll up my sleeves and
actually configure jira
go figure but um i even wrote a paper
for the university about the agile
development life cycle
and and i'll tell you why i think that
once you sit down to configure a
workflow
and it really enforces you to think
about the process and enforce different
steps in the process for example
and when you have to define all the
statuses you have in the workflow so now
it makes you think
does every task need to go through
testing for example
if you decide yes then you build a
status called testing and that's it from
now until forever every task will
have to go through testing and that's an
amazing way to enforce processes across
the organization in a very scalable way
with very little effort
right right you know a selfish question
because i've been in this heated debate
for for many years since my time in the
8200 unit
task story points uh whoever doesn't
know
attach oh i i see that we're gonna enjoy
the debate here
this the notion is uh for anybody who
doesn't understand jira
or or scrum in general the idea here is
that you're assigning tasks and while
in day to day we we ask each other how
long is the task going to take you
jira and jira you assign um story points
to a task based on
complexity now some choose to continue
working through a time
others choose to work through complexity
they have their pros and cons but
but mikhail i'd love for you to explain
to me a little bit about the pros and
cons of each
because in every organization that i've
been a part of i've seen the good the
bad and the ugly of both approaches
and and it just seems like there still
is no convergence on one perfect
approach
that's an amazing question and i'm still
i i personally have a love-hate
relationship with story points
because on the one hand it's it's
psychologically for people it's much
easier to give story points instead of
saying it's going to take me four hours
so usually you define what is the story
point right for the people who's not
familiar with this you just say what's
the time unit that each
story point is equal to so when you're
giving
storyboard when you're and you're giving
your estimation the story points you're
really giving your time estimation but
people
are having it uh they're having a much
easier time
saying it in story points instead of
hours so i do like that aspect of making
it easier for people to adopt this
approach because
one of the most difficult things of
moving into an agile
development life cycle is the adoption
so
engineers tend to hate it and
so so this is one thing that can make it
easier
and i do have to say so that i i
personally don't like it because why not
just say how much time it's going to
take you but because i'm very practical
and but i do like it because jira has a
built-in tool to measure velocity
through it so
if you do use story points you can very
easily measure
how many tasks you can do in atta in a
sprint sprint is a
interval of a few a week or two or three
that
the team is working in um if you're
doing scrum we can go into
a kanban also if you want but uh i don't
know if you want to go into the world of
agile
and so love hate relationship but
definitely i recommend estimations and
choosing one path and take going with it
wonderful so so consistency that then
that's that's the main key right so
there's pros and cons of each but but
consistency is the key
and so when you're entering these
organizations how
what tangibly do you do with jira why
are you considered the jira queen of
these organizations
because i'm i enforce the entire
organization to move to jira
and when they don't do it i i do it
myself and i configure it i can figure
it myself
and so on on the first company i've been
with after the army
they're called the mc mobile care expert
they're selling into the telcom space
so we we got to a place where we were we
were 70 people in the r d
already 70 developers and and we were
managing everything every team was
managing their tasks differently
and we implemented the waterfall
waterfall is a
it's a very old um methodology where
like a waterfall you have different
steps in the process so you
for example you have design and then
design review and then development and
then
testing and then another review and it's
usually a very long process it's a very
good way to manage things at scale
because it's very
um it's very determined but it means
that you have a very long development
lifecycle because if you have all these
steps in the process
the process takes a long time so it's
usually like a release cycle of
even six months to release a new version
and
so we we took a 70 people rnd and we
moved them from waterfall
to to scrum to two week sprints and we
started with two weeks
we ended up after um six months moving
to one week sprint
which is amazing in my eyes and
and i did it back then as i was the vp
of project management so it was part of
my role to do that
and internal processes as well as
external
customer facing processes that was the
my main
responsibility so we did it very
organized we took an external company
that helps us
um educate people on what is scrum and
how does the sprint work and all the key
terms
which taught me a lot and then i was
able to do the same for the other two
companies i've been with
wonderful wonderful that now that that's
incredible and the
difference you know at what point of a
startup's life cycle is it really
relevant do you think to
to start adopting this this methodology
and not just
agile because obviously i think you know
the earlier the start of the more
crucial it is to to be agile
and be open to pivoting and for for
quick feedback but in terms of the
tangibly of operating it through a
software like jira or any other
is it from day one is it from employee
number 30
is there some some rule of thumb that
you're starting to
to understand as you're going through
these different organizations
absolutely as soon as something falls
between the cracks
as soon as as soon as what you currently
have in place is not good enough
and if tasks are not being done on time
or um someone has to keep following up
with everyone to make sure they're being
done
and then that's when you need to scale
it that's when you need to scale it okay
so
20 minutes are almost over but i want to
i want to go back a little bit to
a to performing arts and just as a segue
into who you are and what you're
passionate about you've
taken on a variety of roles you were
talking about performing arts to scrum
methodology to
uh to processes to conversational ai
what are you really passionate about
what how do you choose what you spend
your valuable hours of the day doing
um i think i would define it as i'm
passionate about technology
so startups that are working on
cutting-edge technology
and and also making customers happy so
if it's a technology
that involves a lot of work closely with
the with customers i like to work with
big organizations so enterprises
and and build those genuine
relationships that
are for the long term not just like a
very short project so
continuous work continuous work and
showing value over time
and that's what i'm really passionate
about and scaling internal processes
i love it okay and before we leave i
need three words that you would choose
to describe yourself or that your
co-founders would choose to describe you
okay great so i i saw i watched a bunch
of your your episodes i was ready with
this question
i have to say that the exercise of
deciding on three words is awesome and i
recommend it to everyone
and so the first word is problematic
because it's in hebrew because i
couldn't find a good parallel in english
so i'll explain what it means it's a
bulldozer
okay and that's what it means in here
that's what it is in hebrew
in english it means if the literal
meaning is a truck that breaks stones
and it's a word that's commonly used to
describe people who make
things happen so that's my first word
and then the
the second and third is the obsessive
and passionate
boulders are obsessive and passionate i
have to say that boulder might be
my favorite word out of almost 200
episodes i guess that's
600 words it's a it's just wonderful
mikhail
this was a this was wonderful this was
insightful thank you for the time i know
how busy you are and the masala on your
birthday
which was just recently right uh so in
your book
thank you thank you hopefully by the
time this airs it will be out we're
doing the final touches
uh at least now we know how hard it is
but but this was a this was just a
wonderful conversation so today
thank you this was super fun